Salut à vous les membres de la Team Mentalo,
avec un "O".
Je change tout ce que j'avais prévu aujourd'hui
pour faire une nouvelle vidéo,
J'ai même pas eu le temps de mettre un Tee-Shirt sympa et tout
pour vous parlez d'un clash
que j'ai subi
Hier soir
Je vous laisse découvrir ce que j'ai pu lire sur Twitter et sur Facebook
très sympathique,
Ça provient de la chaîne des Colocs
La chaîne des Colocs, je me suis abonné à cette chaîne je crois au mois de Janvier ou Février
on avait discuté ensemble, on avait même des projets ensemble
Et c'est vrai qu'après j'ai pas répondu
donc ils m'ont accusé d'avoir pris la grosse tête ces derniers mois.
Bref je pense qu'ils cherchent à se venger
Et je trouvais pas ça très cool les mecs
puisqu’à la base moi j'avais décidé un jour de parler de votre chaîne,
parce que j'aime bien vos clips.
Et vous, avec ce que vous avez mis, je vous avoue que ça passe l'envie.
Alors oui j'ai répondu d'une manière un petit peu agressive
mais en même temps, c'était normal que je me défende
Alors, maintenant je vais vous dire quelque chose et ça
vous pourrez pas le censurer comme sur...
*Coupure image*
Les Colocs [Voix Très aigu] : Alors, on a pris le contrôle de ta... *tousse*
[Voix Normal] : Alors, on a pris le contrôle de ta chaîne Olicard
C'est nous qui t'nons les rênes
et on va semer la zizanie
Youhahaha
Pardon
Arbitre : Que le match commence
*Siffle*
*Début de la musique Rock*
1      2      3
On a découvert une chaine Youtube
celle d'un charlatan, d'une crapule
cette soudaine impression qu'on nous entube
d'un homme qui ment sans scrupule
O toi Fab tu crois tirer les ficelles
Tu devrais t'arrêter avant qu'on s'énerve
mais t'es qu'un arnaqueur professionnel
t'as combien de boîte de maïs dans ta réserve
Toutes tes vidéos sont re-coupées
Nous la team Mentalo
Tu re-tournes à chaque fois qu'tu t'es trompé
On en fait du sirop
Tu prétend connaître l'annuaire par coeur
et être bien meilleur qu' Akinator
Olicard, mentaliste en carton
autant d'abonnés car tes potes complices sont bons
Olicard, tu brises les rêves d'enfants
qui n'peuvent plus jouer au 'Qui est ce ' en plus d' 3 coups gagnant
Fabien: J'ai du mal à trouver votre chaîne Youtube
Colocs: Elle n'est regardée que par très peu de gens
F: pas moins de 20 chansons pas 1 seul Tube
C: bienvenue sur la chaine des abonnés absent
F: Les Coloc's soit disant musiciens
C: notre talent est plus petit que les couilles d'un nain
F: mais sans vos logiciels vous seriez rien
C: pour les boites de maïs, il en a 80.
F: Vos vidéos n'dépassent pas les 10 000
C: Nous la team grenadine
F: sauf 1 seule grâce à l'aide de la ville
C: mettons-la en sourdine
F: parlons de vos talents d'écriture
vous arrivez à faire pire que le spectacle d'Arthur
Les Coloc's, humoriste en carton
arrêtez Youtube, allez sur Daylimotion
Les Coloc's, vous brisez la variété
en plus y'en a qu'un seul qui sait vraiment chanter
*Musique cesse*
F: Ok, j'ai une truc qui va nous départager les mecs
on va faire une partie de Chifoumi en 2 manches gagnantes
*Musique reprend*
C: Olicard, mentaliste en béton
Un magicien hors pair qu'on a eu pour de bon
F: Les Coloc's, humoristes loufoques
continuez de chanter
C: On va s'faire mentaliser
*fin du clip*
F: Bon alors, vous en avez pensé quoi?
Oui je me cache parce que ça fait très bizarre de me voir chanter.
Alors, contrairement à eux je ne suis pas chanteur, je ne suis pas musicien
c'était vraiment un délire, qu'on avait avec eux depuis le mois de février
On l'a enfin fait
J'espère que ça vous a fait marrer, ça n'a pas la prétention à devenir le tube du siècle
mais juste à vous faire marrer
Nous, on a kiffé faire ça, c'était drôle et c'est définitif
Je sais vraiment pas chanter
pourtant ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont pu pour m'aider
Je vous invite vraiment à aller voir ce qu'ils font sur leur chaîne
et si ça vous plait évidemment à vous abonner
J'espère vraiment que ça va leur donner un coup de main, parce qu'ils le méritent
Je kiffe ça, moi, depuis je vous dis, janvier ou février
Je m'étais abonné, je suis ça et j'étais ravi
il y a quelques semaines de pouvoir aller tourner ça avec eux
Evidemment, avant de partir je me suis fait un petit plaisir
je les ai mentalisé
et je ne met pas la vidéo sur ma chaîne je leur ai redonné les rushs
et c'est eux qui vont mettre la vidéo sur leur propre chaîne
donc en allant découvrir les autres chansons, les autres clips vous allez surtout pouvoir me voir les mentaliser en même temps.
Voilà je pense pas refaire un clip, un jour sur cette chaîne
C'était un trip, on l'a fait et je tenais vraiment à les remercier
et à la féliciter pour ça. Ils ont été hyper patient durant 2 jours avec moi
Si vous avez aimé ça, si ça vous a fait rire, vous pouvez mettre un petit pouce en l'air
vraiment que si ça vous a plu
et vous pouvez également dire dans les commentaires ce que vous en avez pensé
j'irai lire ça cesoir et demain
pour me délecter de vos petits avis
Abonnez vous à la chaîne des Colocs et aussi abonnez vous à la mienne avant de partir si ce n'est pas déjà fait
Rendez vous demain à 17h
Tchao !